artists have a common language and that  language has no borders the academy's  international outreach has gone to Iran  Vietnam Cuba and we've been very  interested in Africa for quite a period  of time what's great about the  international outreach committee is that  the motive is to reach across the world  talking to people exchanging ideas with  your counterparts in different countries  in different cultures a lot of training  programs take place and a lot of  professional opportunities are created  so that national film industries can  really grow we try to make sure that our  committee has writers directors  producers actors cinematographers  editors so that we can offer that type  of expertise to the filmmakers in the  countries were working with I'm  expecting amazing stories and points of  view to come out of this East Africa  trip